you are a vision thank you thank you the
necklace I feel like it's a nice
it's a little pop a little purple put a
little color into it yeah it also as a
knot I feel like so what kind is it it
is it is it all is it all is it's all a
nod it's all an honor Chad very clearly
still has a huge impact on people and
all we want to do is make sure that that
Legacy continues and we continue giving
back and we continue moving with his
ideals and with his beliefs and
uplifting the community tell me how to
best protect wakanda I want to be a
great king Baba
I hope you're doing as well as you can
be expected yeah you know you get
through
God you know I mean that's really it
grief is is a lifelong battle it doesn't
go away it really it moves in it takes a
seat it says get used to me you know you
don't really get over anything you just
continue you just learn how to carry
this weight that you're now stuck with
and some days the weight feels heavier
and some days it feels a little lighter
and even that lightness feels heavy in
and of itself so it's it's complicated
um but I'm doing my best and and the sun
rises the next day and we have to keep
moving
what are some of those memories or
moments that you turn to and that you
constantly have in your heart and in
your mind about Chadwick to get you
through the heaviest of moments you know
it was such a lesson and he was such a
teacher that I think being able to
really watch him work and watch how he
made decisions and watch how he really
thought and meditated and put himself in
other people's shoes and tried to look
at a situation from every single angle
is something that I will never I will
never it would ever be lost to me you
know
um
there are too many moments to really
name one you know there are too many
moments Ryan told me that he did bring
you into the fold to ask your opinion
your thoughts on how they could
incorporate Frederick's memory his
legacy how did that make you feel that
Ryan reached out to you tonight you know
Ryan is unlike many many most people he
has such a deep love for Chad and also a
deep respect for him and you know I feel
so blessed that they are the family and
the team that continue telling this
story that continue the Black Panther
franchise because I don't know that
anyone else could do it but Ryan I
struggle to even find the word but it
really I cried when he called me you
know to ask me my thoughts and say is
this you know how do you feel about this
and I think that he really has done a
beautiful job of reflecting what the
reality of grief is and it is that it
doesn't leave but other things happen in
the world and and we can't just lay down
and and stop our work we really do have
to keep moving and he's done that both
behind the camera
um and with what everyone will see
[Music]